[music]
in the first game of the final match grant
hour tour in london hikaru nakamura
played the opening unsuccessfully with White and already
after 20 moves was forced to switch to
protection
Maxim yours I didn't use all the logs
chances of a profitable ending and allowed
hikaru achieve a draw in this match
equal as in the fight for third place
between caruana and ryan phone without
special problems
equalized in the opening and achieved a draw with
we have been waiting for positions of power for more than a month
scoring game in classical
London and there is hope that a draw
the curse will be broken today
don't miss the second game day
starts right now
[music]
good afternoon dear friends and good morning
petru veniamin h svidler who is nearby
with me in the studio in st louis before
I remind you that it's still 8 am
nothing has been exchanged so sometimes water
what to 1 rand sync with
introductory video but I just
amazed me it seems that there is now on
screen man slept and in london a u
it's two o'clock in the afternoon it's perfect
unforgivably so wonderful
event we are watching a man sat down in
front row and speed we get him drunk
well we don't approve yes well maybe that's it
understand this as the most honest
spectator don't fix fix really
interesting enough party and tonight
here with such colors with white playing
your kilos can be interesting in
final and in the match for third place overall
it seems to me there will be no passing parties
yesterday we discussed before added to dinner with
comrades again
what is the probability that he
repeat Hikaru's strategic decision
nakamura will just make a draw with white
against
Fabian we think that practically
zero as for the final match
I had already won one in this tournament
nice and such an important game against
Berlin endgame which also
is Nakamura's repertoire debut
so we can do it today
look for one more berlin and i
I think that from afar you can see what delight
cause it's vista cause
undoubted delight let me remind you what it is
after all, there was a fast chess game and I
there is still some hope
any debut starts with the letter n
pit mind variant bustard in performance
hikaru probably won't be the best
Let's just say it's not the smartest decision.
considering that maxim entered the logs of such
I will find parts of the forest for shoes for both colors
rf plays yes but let's do it for now
let's walk as usual before the start of the broadcast
because it happened throughout the schedule
which we actually prepared
Let's start with why these
four people play with us in london
finale yes here is the position after four
qualifying stages of the Grand Hour Tour before
the beginning of the final point of the console in london
no one else won the hikaru tournament
won very confidently because it
first place is even after division
last in the final and most
chief dad
Evolving Points Tournament Cup Sim
Phil Yes, that is, you can understand how
stock yes with such stock nakamura
selected thanks precisely here perhaps
game of chess with shortened controls
mida second place for levon aronian a
who divided the first in the last
tournament 3rd place maximizing your kilograms up to
4 ranked cow by dividing 4 5 6 beating
its on tie breaks yes here here here to us
show
after the semi-finals the score of the property is
not counting the final of 1818 and both matches
semi-finals ended with
picture on look and upright annie
bezant alno yes yes yes yes that is
nakamura beat the bark and well with the score
1810 Yes, I ate it Count with the same
score 1810 we'll talk about the system
scoring won in the second
semi-final at the lemon
she, respectively, here is the finale for you
Nakamura fried the Count and finalized him
or the final match in the match for the third
place score now 66 and why score 66 we
you now actually mark 33
which won't you get ahead of yourself
no one is the result that we
I would like to take a look at the system
scoring for tournament format I think
that we have more or less explained about it
Well, once again, she once again told about
this is necessary here again and so 2 classics
Yesterday we played the first game of classical
draw as expected today there is hope
that somehow deviated from the schedule yes for
victory in the classic starts cord
actually the party in the classics costs 6
points yes for a win 6 with a draw each
gets three points for exactly that and
happened yesterday and finally the funniest
day
most likely we are waiting for tomorrow where they will play
two parties wrapped 4 in a blitz party in
rapida rapid chess is worth 4 points per
blitz 2 points for time control
screen and staring clearly everywhere
strange letter w which means that
the very delay instead of the addition
we talked a lot about the difference between these
two controls my delay leads to
more rigid cycle but there so let's say
because it is impossible to accumulate time and
need to be more precise
plan your time for
throughout the entire time he plans his
waste of time including sometimes
spending this delay time in
reflections on quite obviously started
velo ladies, oddly enough, yes, this is it
I find it very hard to adjust
almost impossible yes it is one
of things that are obviously right
there is let's say it's profitable to think in the classics 29
seconds over let's say in the Berlin endgame
taking king and 8 to 8 friend
no one can do it the only way
does not yes although it is from the point of view
again here is the clean linen expected
this is absolutely correct
yeah well let's look at the schedule but
such an unpretentious today's broadcast already
has begun and tomorrow will begin
exactly at the same time, well, here it is
By the way, I'm glad because they were
precedents started a couple of hours earlier
you know, well, we would actually survive
because we get up at 5 am chronically
here but you players would be unpleasant i
rather for the players cancer what's the last
day they are not forced to stray from already
established
rhythm so yes today here we begin
8 local at 2:00 London time there are 5
in Moscow and the same thing will happen tomorrow
ok let's look at the profiles
participants up to actually they are fast it
no profile and so
Maximize your loggers who are today
plays with white here is the third
place in the selection in the qualifying tournament
grand astor which actually
consists of two very successful
the result is fast and blitz is an infusion
and and site luis and two places among not
tables in paris so to speak at home
field yes exactly single copy in singular
classic tournament but again
confidently again, we repeat that how
somewhat regardless of whether he is in
in the end he was beaten by 3 credits
points in the qualifying tournament bracket as
since the fact that they are dealing with london
almost at the same time during
Cup synchronously was not questioned
color levan needed to win
the last batch to ensure exactly
imagine exiting the final tournament so led
just very reliably selected for the final
and the final is already playing for the title of champion
plays today with white against hikaru
nakamura yes she who did we already tell
that I passed the selection very confidently
I remember here his interview before Sept.
field cap before and after victory in
st louis rapid blitz and he said that
yes, now you can finally calm down
I want to play chess without pressure
play a good tournament good tournament not
got hit u yeah he shared the reign
place can be without pressure turned out
but a good tournament anew did not come out that
can actually be revealing
as a chess player in general I
it seems easier even to play when something
something something on the eve somehow easier
motivate yourself address well on
throughout your career you get used to choosing
under some stress and not that I
played through the sleeves hikaru but that's what
maybe something was missing
no matter how the maximum
prize money so far 1 1 1 place and again
the only person who won
two tournament his and there cash in 221
two stage wins in paris are given here
which we will look at the participants of the match for
third place yes today we have white
magnet wait I'm getting ahead of myself again
statistics and here are the possible pairs of the final
data anyway would have developed here
perhaps the most so to say
one way on you one way
the skew is large, that is, a big plus for
hikaru by now judging because we see
on the screen just not a single party of maxims
did not win classical chess yes
then I first saw this particular
score between two obviously very strong
chess players who have been playing for many years
music for me it was honestly a shock
because intuitively it does not seem that
hikaru should
agro mine dara contagion cook
outplay them, but nonetheless
this is the state of things today
would like to change this situation
because the victory in the classic game
considering the format of the tournament gives him
a huge stock before the final day yes
and moreover, in this particular pair
absolutely impossible to predict
favorite on the third day when it comes
up fast and blitz so naturally
such a backlog
the classics would be very much helped by an advantage in
six points before before the start
the last day, of course, would not be
ensures him victory in the match he gives
of course he has much more peace of mind
Well, now you're finally without false artem
match for third place yes let's
let's see the profiles so straight levon aronian
hell second place in the selection as we said
largely thanks to the victory in the last
round, respectively, the victory of the same 1 3 in
synclit copy fell a little short of
three-digit sum six-digit sum
three digits in thousands when prize money
up to six digits but this is fixable because
which is natural in the last tournament
too played out serious enough
the skin of his opponent is a contender for the world
the crown of Fabiano Caruana, who is also in this
tournament, as if to say that with
it's been happening lately
facet 6 it took shape you see on
screen two very heavy tournaments
held in June
penultimate infusion site
penultimate place in paris but on its own
home territory since fabi
now in general registered thoroughly
the whole torso he took so good
working fourth place in europe deine
glitzy and
shared the first with magnus or out
amaroni and all of us with silks and such
way
just got into interruptions over the past
coming 4th beat 800 and
and reached the final as for him
the last 30 days, then in general you can
talk about what he probably already
should slowly get tired of this
situations where he plays very decently
it's hard to win classics for a game
then his minds europe 2 win
rabbi tables yes and that's what I would like
maybe he also has something in this picture
change so well, as I understand it slide
with statistics we have somewhere a little later
will appear on the screen between Aronian them
pockets
I can tell from memory what I think
is he stuffed some kind of plus so far
Fabian just got up or there
there is any after all and older and already
quite a long time ago it was mined on the first lines
world ranking, that is, in some
moment it's all sad enough for
Fabian finish but here's the last
years rather the situation back and the world
Escape Candidates Tournament won
fabiana pre 76 classic leads fabiana
I think that just at the expense of recent years
when the dynamics changed there and well, too
very interesting couple and how I
I remember there 76 at some relatively
her and not a small number of draws then
there are quite a lot of them and
azada we talked with you that about 40
percent yes on such new batches up
the prize pool of the tournament will call
zonal tournament in London 300 thousand
dollars
total prize fund of 120 thousand for the first
place 80 for the second and respectively two
less times played in a match for
third and fourth place 60 winner
40 losers and there are no more
credit points returning to questions from
chateau yes how is it like this tournament
this tournament is considered
final tournament of certain credit points
already all the credit points were in the qualifying
stage and now just a winner
final match nakamura of your logres
will actually be declared the winner.
large-scale this series of Grand Hour Tour
2018 what we see appear on the screen
participants and again both or van damme
participants in the match for third place over
disciplined anticipating potentially
questions that may arise
participants people watching this
broadcast on the same stage
british championship final
the final match between Gawain im
Jones and Luke Mage Shane and the match for
third place between
this scene this scene is olympia
alligator alligator to the Lenkom Theater and
saloons finalists before it seems too
pulled up until we see
participants when the UK
yes, just yesterday we are taught on this in
chat there was a question what is michael doing there
adams let's chief himself play chess
allowance not eaten and amazing doing something
what he is supposed to do for what
he was born, I would even say with
confidence
here slowly flock flock
participants are generally
blacked out as befits a theater
auditorium but it is clear that there are people and
here is the main organizer
historically all these major London
tournaments malt read some something
and ask why read further
I wave as it should be in the theater, this is the beginning
should have been at two o'clock in the afternoon but this
a slight delay on n that is the third
we see the call now that's maxim yes through
bar another promising junior will
do 1 honda
Well, yesterday was such a strange moment
happened yes what kind of hikara went e2 e4
yes, and then he took this move back, but also
here im well too our sex wondering in
the house went up to the angel probably trying
do the same because had up to 4
he rarely walks, he is generally one of the few
modern top players who are not
not able to not go and 4 on
first move to back azat party
the shaman has reached b kwan and now let's see
on the first move, but I would be very surprised not
and not seeing the move and 2 and 4 here the maximum is
i.e. did the same trick yesterday
no mirror trick pulled by hikaru
nakamura went for him e2 e4 he changed
move to d4 then what is berlin
nowhere to go, but here are the neighbors
very similar to what
expecto berlin we will have
organize and what is not now a horse
go no one plays the main
spanish almost never therefore
if from someone else let's say it is quite
mashalla may try to play that
the time when I see something it seems to me but
gave some yes and more we have
Russian party
Levon has an open day today
debuts but just here are two open
debuts that are usually not enthusiastic
aroused in the background by fill up fill up
such an existential horror generation
audience yes, everything is clear so far
surprise so far what's happening on the board
does not cause, and again, that's what we are talking about
said in principle they could on 29
a second to be over each of these moves
it doesn't make sense ever kind new
good old days if the base
check date here is berlin this one
endgame subtracted from what Kramnik started
play at the highest level yes but at the very
actually played almost drank Sberbank not yet
it goes without saying how very hard
come up with brand new things and you know
what did they do so long ago in 900 some in
Start
that is, White moved the knight c3, that's what
then especially naive comrades dressed black
elephant and 7 followed by white linen on
device that is black stole berlin with
the possibility of castling long you are
already of course it is shocking and even today
apparently he entered will check
Hikaru's memory in absolutely central
line of course this is this is quite this
a little sad because it was good
to know something but I'm definitely nothing at all
I don't know in this line I'm serious
look at berlin seems to me approximately
to be honest, that's exactly variants h5
this makes me so depressed
personally that but there is a feeling that not
it means in general it’s more like
mechanical memory yes that is black
almost there at the moment
exclusively for mechanical memory
because
very like a complicated option which a
here is vladimir especially these positions
game 4 date was this enchanting party
Karjakin with whom he and I played
this is what they went against
some pawns on each flank passed in
queens and white in the center almost played
not two with whom it was which I don’t remember
which both of the opponents had everything
to the end recorded exhaustion so
complicated that they both spent about
two hours remembering all of them on i
remembering all the necessary move the tank is not 4
attacked must
I own a6 well, what can you hold 6 apparently
well so dad mind clothes 6 but then again
again, it would be nice to know something yes yes yes
Well, the guys certainly know something
as a question to us but here for example very
would not prevent us from going to the studio of some
specialist and again I don’t don’t
instead of my favorite beloved friend
sitting next to him as a third
man here here alexander grischuk and
of course invite which would us all
I talked about this position
I feel a little confused and
surprise did not follow show
instant karma because it's supposed to
should be almost central body
although I think it may be, but not at all
meet walk in connection with
followed by such she has four looks
extremely unnatural therefore to
well, come on, let's then options
figuring out some dala keepin eating
let's say what's what's white's idea because
that the ambassador holds 6 to 7 b6 I want apparently
yes there limit this here 18 and
always water, as it were, as an idea
potential to 65 naturally but in
principle to exchange one pair of rooks in
feature if we would already go 6
because then let's say at service 5
jackal grandfather one king can run across
through through d888 because you know me
they say that the move h5 h4 is almost on win
I also haven't seen this before
but believe that it might be new
an option with an expense, well, as it were, here
it's absolutely absolutely central
samba 4 theory is also not caruso chief
hall logical yes yes and here is a3
from Icelander 3 pc gamer but they went
there might be some other hanya here
sow or something they went to some thread
the horse starts somewhere rather quickly
jump given but these row options
appear to attack I'm sorry for
absolutely pointless arrows
attack lay on occasion yes and
White's weaknesses on the queenside yes
if h4 is new, then it is all the more strange that
after horses 4 thought and bark because
well, all the horse bounces in response to our 4th
ideas need to be carefully considered.
clothes 6 would like to probably go elephant
same 5 but the problem is that I don't understand
how to react to scrapping d5 creating
beat such an unambiguous threat
beat give when here f4 in 4 like this
design it does not call at all
no trust in me to the point
that I'll go say b6 then so
villains 6 will threaten everyone in 6 and
there are some on spiers in Berlin
tactical motives are connected with
open checks but not here obviously
number on 6 strong korolev 8 strong
will never pass what it is
now move number 5 we have move number 17
17 yes that is it's all just me here in
uh i have
lives benson who gives periodically
useful information is the producer of our
show yes and here he says that October 10
at the Olympics, it seems to have been played between
these same two people do not succeed
you won’t give 4, apparently somewhere, well, in general, everything
the same played the same color
looks like the game ended in a draw
times for berlin it don't need his ashes
you keep the same six plays haru m was
basically like me in i watched it a lot
playing white berlin spire he is not
is not engaged in Hollywood that is, if u
it's all good look at we how
once his moves we will see instantly he
not
don't try to waste time
imitating imitating reflections so by
at least from his side
the party will develop very rapidly
late 5 here I am seen 5 before but
do we want after h4 as far as we
satisfied with such a diamond for 6 I wanted
put on 6 owner 8 is not true
I understand that he is the case and there is still him
get caught in some kind of t-54 and start
rushing 534 there it doesn't look like
promising
Now I'm a little embarrassed
really want no matter how
at least from the audience not much
fall behind knowledge about this position
so I thought I'll see what
actually they had at the Olympics well
for this I need some pause
which has no natural fillet
what move actually can here
white do so she has four strange
even in a sense that is once again
and here 4 here and there 4 here and there
there will be games, but it's so simple that is
it is so important to drive away the end of f5
that I’m ready to somehow loosen a little
structure black pro usually usually white
no no no really [ __ ] smash pawns on
own kingside but in this
in a specific case, yes, in principle, this one
variant of villains and one elephant 243 in it
such as say chipping from childhood
good looking rules
structures to which they should aspire
often generally wrong
discarded due to the fact that the game
becomes extremely specific so but
have already played
even the same goo played naturally
because blacks can't afford
White will not keep the pawn on d4
try to play the famous video
check and pass here but if
do you want to be on the ship
this needs to be done now
that's why hikaru was alone
Known for a very party in Berlin
ending where [ __ ] 24 wasn't done yeah
this is me saying of course the party from the match
kasparov kramnik denmark who me
seems to have already entered into all modern
textbooks on tactics not days positions
already twice four
harry got the upper hand
precisely because the taking on the aisle was
unfavorable thread all right with taking
on the aisle well, what thinness 6 probably
breathe flags 1 7 evil not for 5 possible
beforehand to her again may be in
Plan 7 I wanted just in time for the position
friction putting our 6th yes probably in what
idea . what would be good for her
if this tactic passed, but it
obviously does not pass because coins and
4 protected and of course still gave birth to a grandfather
so really here in general
there are serious problems with this
rook if its there
white will be able to immure tachenko that
won't she have fun they'll have on
essentially send one fighter less
I wonder what black seems to be better
actually write better
walking structure given exactly white here
in this position
probably ready to play slowly yes then
there is somehow to retreat like an elephant and not
let out laden there to role in twice
king try
from black durham world to its not
some kind of precision
mobilize figures arrows what he thinks
hikaru we are still hikaru and even give birth
maybe really horses 4 same 4 some
a small surprise such can be given
walker her 4 looks pretty
natural again here too
understand that when people started
watch Berlin again if you take
modern
but the new era of berlin on the spire is
undoubtedly at the origins of the game of Berlin were
for tonal mouse and belarusian chess player
alexey alexander exe alexandra yes they
of course there were two
pioneers but for good of course
dibil's debut exploded supplies him
played by Kramnik as the main opening against
Kasparov in London and London and indeed
did not win a single game in Berlin
and at first they looked at him as a kind
concept debut in which
operated exactly
precisely the questions which figures are in the mode
day I and then it is better to change such figures
as we say, he actively debuted
the question is whether white wins
ending follow beat on and 6 come on ya
I remember that they entered a serious won yes yes
Yes, there were serious debates
is it possible to win some
such a pin and there let's say what figures
need to change at this time
provide and elephant there, let's say they can
white can win such an elephant
you loved such a horse and so on
but now the weight is actually studying
Berlin in particular in the sage 5 variant
transferred to in general it's kind of like
on the other hand, the spire is very sharp and
its not that desirable needed
watch with computer with development
modern robotics should be
it is said that is can be seen sometimes
so strange to the human eye
continuation here and therefore actually here
in the nineteenth care white in appearance
destroyed their positions all that is usual
tore first forced to beat the zither
report earlier there then still 4
Sullivan, but at the same time it is certain that
had it all done no-no-no-no as it were
this is consciously this is not an imitation of activity
he's sure it's at least
good test for one batch or maybe
be he really believes that white
it's better here
yeah the game is getting extremely berlin
concrete lately again
I repeat in particular in this
its forking us with hand side with
the other side if that's how they say
it’s easier for me and I don’t understand anything, and
in addition to it is not clear why that's impossible
somehow schematically even left this boat
on the same 6, play b65 and somehow there
the knight can be through and this even on c6
send yea d5 me me really
really interested in this question
back dedicated to ask if I go
here elephant up to 5 what is recommended
make a move with white because I am very
as if again the structure on me is very
interested in the question if I go elephant before 5
on almost any stroke on the volumetric and 4
I will go to hold 6 and 6 5 years given that
whites are destroyed by themselves and not
destroyed destroyed but smashed
structure on royal as far as it
bad on black well, apparently I have to
then play here 4 probably 4 we
we go yes here I go just for you this
comfortable was not from you took took kuni
7 maybe I'll have time 6 right here
like do we really want to go
I am 6 or or white as if playing extremely
slowly say there shorter 2 king same 3
and try sashki right up try on
perspective to create a remote gatehouse
on the verticals and black in response, as it were
here is the control standard counterplay
blacks especially if you own
if she is tied say sc5 then rook
often in the sixth row that's different from
6 up to connects to attack this one
these are the firewood that the whites have on
on the queenside
extremely sharp spire, well, what is it about
Eugene also spoke completely
right and move 6 is quite logical and
another thing is that you owe so much the same
past me on what's let's say nt-5 servants 5
I don't have time to go again, that is, to me
maybe you need to start with the move b-52
also bishops 5 already seems to be in possession of black
until 6 some 16 I was going to walk to
im under 5 do need this
options they all so stopped at
season 5 to
what i would i thought very hard i took
king they are difficult variations rook c6
rook e6 king to 7 and remained very
happy with them
as if 5 of course was my gold then
eat us it might just be
risky went because here
after horse before 5 elephants 5 I don't have time
to protect themselves from the servant of the family, let's say
on the king at 7 for 4 they will lead the edges for 24 to
my happiness is the move kanebo 65 fathers 5 2
lights up collapse 4 very sad and on
horse at 6 I went to 5 at last
decisive geteasy hmm and that's already there
rushed to the field to 7 and there most likely everything
white wins just though too
of course you can try what is spinning at
me even this finger can not be
quite hopeless but no joy
no matter what the king is on 5
get out therefore to you the only reason
on which you don't have to stay for now
black is what i go out with the reward
we may be in a hurry with the code 5
Well, this version of ours was owned by Dima
create or even just the king of the same 12
zeros just to start only
intensify because packed black
a little yes, well, in general, there are some
scenarios for the development of events in which
blacks here won't get enough contour
games yes, and again, if you surround the codes
who were treated in this n people
who knows nothing about her
definitely water up 8 trying some more
slightly simplify the same motto 3
less memory about more change
new star but here actually gave
Diaz of problems is that it can be
pretty strong elephant same 5 i don't know
how much but at least weave
seriously consider Iran's realities
such a simple tactic elephant up to 54
which I think is still a horse
e34 kohl budget fire budget and there
the truth of hell is strong because i
there was an illusion cd
well then attacked the horse went on and 6j ghd
curious plantings but not curious at
her 4 2 times and balls 5 had alcoves knives
5 something like threats and Canada 8 cargo
d-yes, yes, it doesn’t work, that is, it can
maybe it's possible to finish harrison up to 5 for and
to the icon you are so cute too
geometry or distracted elephant and more
no mate need 8 or just eaten on c4
this pawn and who tried to attack
our elephant is therefore on the water until 8 apparently
need something different
white sleep can just ignore this
size went the same 4 again summed up there
we need three kings, we continue as if nothing
never happened from the series I know my next
there are 3-4 intercessors and I don't really care not
very interested there do do what
if you want, do what you must and come what may
Well, Hikaru thinks in the house and here in the chat
offer kuni and sim card md5 stop yes
certainly probably one of the
the main moves of this position we will also carry away
pawn h3
he is even 4 on this and we are talking about this
they said yes, and now it’s not on black
must blunder a piece with bishop g4
can go root to 5 elephant soon
just goes where it is called he happens to
we are 11 given api i don't want to get along 6
underwear
I think it is very important to live as much as possible
he is already three rook 6 rook came to
some centered cells up to keep
I own in prison knives 6 it seems to me very
important as long as we have
it would seem so here is the sun on September 1
that here we be some kind of tactical
such wacky slot f5 when try
on maybe using all the same a bunch
along the line
but he again circuit ac3 hangs well you
greatly improved the position of the horse I wanted
say come on let's ignore how
usually all that all that happens yes all
what black do you can again jump like
then attacked the pawn immediately and the size of the elephant
g4 even if it's nothing in play after
kunst ripus owns 60
Yes, if you have time to put you own growth
let's put b5 there it's enough
a decent block is installed on
asks if the first ended in a draw
games ended long ago in both matches
yeah let's actually give hikaru
think a little because
Well, the finger is very difficult offhand moves
blacks have 34 escapes here
looking kai meaningless so yeah
it seems that he is yes if you do not know the answers to
the caller does not know what to do here
yes can be wrapped accordingly
let's see what's going on with us
in the second game in which a little
it makes me sad to look at this landscape and
this brings us back to what i'm talking about
spoke at the very beginning before even
how we began to show the players what
some kind of feeling of deja vu to me
it seems fabiana should be on the drive now
overcome overcome because but this
then even seriously
can't be called a check
happens but it's not like that
would be toothless to the obvious so simple
I propose a draw that Hikaru did
two days ago or how much three days wrong
important how many days ago the playground u
blacks will be an insulator until 5 not
depending on how much they want
swap piece with it or immediately cd
or la 9 to 5 and white can still
put the knight 4 of this in 3g 4 h5
I still think that the party will be
continue, but in general it is clear that the general
the concept is
white came out without any risk to play
some position in which roughly speaking
there will be no chance for scientists to
victory, well, yes, such a half a penny
gave even there further here let's say if
here is some stupidity in black alone
make let's say soldering as if in life
clothes
switch to multicolored after elephant same 5
you can seriously be sad, yes, that's it
fingers just might turn out to be the hardest
no one will go to elephants 6 and
it is important to have the same 5th move on the move and all
at 6, that is, just more than that and
and immediately here, of course, probably ng5 f6
this size is never allowed in this
connection, by the way, I thought that I could put something
still change to d5 yes that's it
Fabiana actually thinks about it
how many figures can you leave
go and so of course to again
elephant for five days there was no ligament
diagonals
give here already on horseback 4 I would be all
equally wanted plywood with no need for slopes i
generally you need a demon until 7 until then there
a6 water and 8 some French
we make moves and after that already
reviewing but in general, as it were, general
evaluation of such positions considering that black
two bishops about the numbers on and a knight they usually
have enough or some counter play
or they always have this here resource
whom Eugene now says attacked and
actually took on killed going on or
clay to some completely already there
such Nazira there is not grain at all I will give
that's why white most likely should
will somehow run away from this exchange then
eat feeding
another problem is also by the way our 4 that is in
Let's show how it is
it turned out again the main toby
now takes the main toby in Russian
Yes, I'm trying to find where the tick is
there is no checkmark anywhere why I don't have
updated second gift the main thing is both
Russian party actually the same option
which Fabian from Nakamura had not
repeat fabio find to 76 which
did against Carlson in game 11
world championship match very sorry yes
it could be funnier at least
positions you interesting options here and
here here is the king would 1 to 5
elephant before 3 and other hikaru here me
it seems they are from kiko walked h4 pretty
early there is such an order, but it seems to me
it was king would 1 to 5 h4 own here
800 apple in that order and here
selected walked the sun 5 cm to 4 beat
beat the knight f6 in general somewhere here already
it became clear that the party would be quite
dry
if I do not confuse anything in my opinion nothing
not something like this for today, is it for you
went inside and immediately got 5's cavalry
answer went h4 in this position beat
some kind of beat is created
semantic threat knight g5 forcing a move
same 76 because it will be quite dangerous
checkmate threat is therefore played from up to 6m
so I think I'll finish 5 pretty
calmly go heart 6 nothing oh yeah
there is no bad
yes, that's why White has 4 pins along the line on
water up to 8 cm, and here we see it means
all these sizes and fave already beat a pawn
I mean that already 4 is absolutely standard
move in these positions because
actually games and Sasha 4 tips almost
not the only source
immediately initiatives which are white
may try to generate here but what
concerns such an endgame and considering
again that black has two bishops
make you feel calmer
rush to h2 somewhere as much as 4 h3 asks
well, that's because because they
need to think potentially
you will need to cut some shapes or
somehow think maybe about expanding
as if north to 4 then maybe
h5 at 34 at ideally so that she doesn't
hung constantly because the beginning of diana
w1 will be tied to the defense of the h-pawn 4 but
in general, let's repeat
whites sometimes achieve something in such
spiked nose but for good of course not
part is already here but here is half an hour of air
there are no queens in any of the games, well
here is the modern theory of open debuts
dorado in childhood taught burn what to play
open debuts you learn to attack
king and so trembled slight depression
evokes of course yes and our team
producers they would give us every day
put a leaf
the schedule of the graphics that we will
show in the first ten minutes of the air
until the parties began and that's between
the third line in which our last name
that every man is very pleased down
their names on a piece of paper and
actually listing all this
charts every day ben simon publishes
there is a new message for us
funny yes today message looks like
last classic game ever
the rest of our lives before before
previous to you, well, two messages were
again all caps crisis in
classical chess and when we ourselves
we start talking about what all this
evokes a certain depression, then in general
hard to get rid of the thought
in fact, this is how things are, but everything is not
so just do not want to at all
already
how to evoke such a stupid thinking
but of course the situation is in with the first move and 4
against people who don't want to play on
and we have bustards in that tournament people
who play it your people who
don't play it against people who don't
play on and bust first move e4
requires good preparation and
once again in the chat to ask what
if there is a draw
probably not first just watch us
yes we talked about the format of the tournament
no matter how it ends
today classic park i even if
someone will win, but it doesn't matter
will be played tomorrow game day
which here consists of two rapidos in 4
blitz today match is not anyway
finished in case not over and over
the same tomorrow all these
six games regardless of the score in
match so yes there is more to say
to provide somehow up to the spectacle
that is, even if the match is won by one of the
the parties are still on schedule
scheduled games are played to the end
well, we'll be back all the same 4 cities 4
played but again, probably
follow the little idea would 5 horse with everyone
there if admit to 56 black
maybe not on this run but in general
they can’t do without where 6 most likely
up to 7 most likely that it cannot but
annoy before
although found in fact I might be
sleep up to 76
if it works out because again in
in the order of illustration, let's layer up to 7
white went to don't know v2 and v3 chon and
let's go a6 there is some idea to go
knights b3 and then there himself would 6 sun 5
Potocki fields to occupy on each flank
be we can data therefore delivered to
it's hard to imagine how
after a little bit to limit the bishop on e3
swimming pools 6 given that we are not
we believe them that white is suddenly something
there to undermine on the queenside
impulse a4 a5 in this game most likely
does not pursue, so to speak, either march
and the idea of ​​an elephant for 5 euros, yes, I think that
in principle, here is such a structure too
me with arrows today is even worse
she looks more than usual
more harmonious than structure in a hurry
on the
6 so we expect something like this and
Let's get back to the final
because if we have today
on board 2 feels honest though
Berlin. call it dry today
can't he have a pretty new coupler
interesting wonder what nakamura is like
hunting hasn't done so far up to thinks then
there is already more than twenty minutes difference in
clock readings, it is clear that
Maxim looked at this position
at home before g4 was done fast maxim
no doubt still in the know yes that's hikaru
finally it converges to the 5th move which we
undoubtedly voiced but the question is really
fact that he would go to the same 4 I suspect
what will 4 be played because in this
very stubborn strategy of the protein is not
they say what now to hangs but also
of course you can defend the move king in 2
like but why undead yes but i don't
I see absolutely no reason
bide your time the same you the same 4 move is
undoubtedly programs and that's the question
will hikaru want to be on e4
right away or does he want to admit and walk
to them on some field there point of view
here to prevent this e6 income which
we consider maybe marten 70
type
well yes your correct one can be start
bow down and again here just like that
to illustrate here temporarily
passes this tactic, but all to what it
brings it absolutely equal opposition
after took took and water and 6 even said
nominally black has the best yes but
Given the show-off multi-colored win
it will most likely be difficult
it is clear that there is fire and 7 what to say
even the horse is not hanging yet, that is
you can approach us at all for some
distracted 26 Ol's abstract move b6 or
water up to 8 but the icon is not 7 for me a little
begins to confuse the course of the marten 5 and there
in the same such restrain your quest 6
a date where somewhere white and a procession like
the country is getting along 86
Elodie cannot be killed, that is, you have to beat
f.u.
com beats sei to role in 7 now
probably from the option from 404 to water to 7 as
you can depend a lot not quite
I understand that something is threatening us
there is a threat 6 basically we are talking here
this is such a black figure is absolutely not
coordinated doesn't have good margins
basically and on the contrary here we go
the strongest compensation is again difficult
say white wins or has
overweight or maybe black exact
somehow jumps off the income I don’t see yes
here 6 monstrous force threat I first
I thought that somehow we will figure out how
answer but so far I can't
figure out how to defend yourself
from the unambiguous idea of ​​going after a horse
there are seven yes exactly horses 7.5 maybe
actually very very serious
thing because the pawn pool is hanging
either 8 looks horribly treated
of course there are specific problems
begin to advance
1 but let's important that no so it's semi
near the line absolutely forced along
sensations skoda 704 pro immediately refills
well done and 86 but you can beat the elephant but
why is this better than the previous one
horse need 5 you guys aren't she right up
to the point that I will go absolutely
such but the breasts were kept in water
gotta 7 hits on the big outside
depending on how much we change
figures up to great fun position
I don't think I called clothes 7 later
layer five especially if they give me
put will give like andy 6 you won't go
given what and how they are up to 5 5 square
hopelessly scientists but also [ __ ] 6 let's say
let's even say the bishop is 3 then h4 and h5
also the position looks like the hardest
maybe it's a plan
profile
so there will be problems until the html is
went to 4 more on slando 5 but expected
on this move for a second you need them
also thou this is more important wanted to ask
can not be divided into go at the end insolent
and slowly 5 oao but still sorry
pity such an important bone can
well 4-ku no 7 we won't be on you no
don't like it there is a swimming pool
b5 of course the cat
She doesn't give much pleasure
maybe it can
well, that is, we leave the end again
actually eternal, yes, but concrete is
such a solution we provide parking for the elephant
on d5, that is, perricone 6 seems to be possible
play king dc
maybe maybe it didn't come
normal and even and as in the head under
pool b5 bow or you give maybe
u should already and should because that would be 6 by
almost loses the feeling and from
nasty you can go baseband
so would yourself 5 that's really disgusting to you
yea and that's how to say alright
alright because it feels like it's in
second game of today's tour now
may
there will be no games to repeat moves even
About Me
alarm alarm it will give and why by type
ended the second is a little sad
especially because yesterday I was our
colleagues
to that of
over there that's 20 and over there yes yes or something
you will beat today and in general
feel like
impudent puddle yes wait and what
something happened
and the caillebotte by the river up to 4 went just otherwise
there is a bishop d7 yes that he is up to 7 somersault
figure 5.4 slando 7 and everything went like this
well, they started to believe their own
so to speak your strength in fast and blitz
but unexpected straight honestly well i'm in i
yesterday you will sleep literally on this occasion
said let's say unexpectedly not that he
considers himself the favorite of glitzy fast a
unexpected refusal to fight white
figures, they knew there, yes, I’m on this
about yesterday he said a long one like
make a heartfelt speech about how
Lemon treats himself with respect and
their profession and water at home today
we'll see said i'm not the first time i
I find myself absolutely out of parks
some question and not the last one so
nothing wrong with us
are discussing here in the chat your brushes bark
kilos in the hall rush yes it is
we also know about it yes we also know about it
we know it and we do it too
that they are all table earthquake is not
with the table it's with the camera with the table all in
okay just someone passed apparently
hooked ramira she staggered wanted
ask when you also 4 played and
all the same, is it good or bad is hikaru
takes the horse but he also appreciated the options
schoolgirl 5 I think while thinking about the elephant
up to 5 root of 7 well, that is, I am the 6th option
yes it is big we showed on the board
20 minutes ago literally and talking about
what they said about what is very
reasonable but except for 6 you can again
you can take it slower yes you can
try yes somehow provides
pawn safety and same 4 start
push the pawn all the way forward because if
imagine that white people will do everything
there are these moves of the king 2 korzha 3rd
and the 5th 6 before then well worth the black finger
critical another thing that is not required
black so many moves board black
probably at what point will it stop
say check and start talking
means to speak up to some there of so
well specifically how we play out of line
six then what muscles 4 attend to all
heat can be cut or cut
skate for now and let's say so
an approximate version of some water and
6 king yes that's it that's it
here is a very powerful pancake same 6 lange 3 up on
f6 probably we are not very upset we
just walk la grandfather and 1 and say that u
we are such a rooker and nicer
welcome, I, too, of course, here I ask
question do you think it's better we don't store it
beat better to them that extraterrestrial tails on
4 h5 there that's how I 400 but that can
be sad all of us do not have time
support the rook
4th step because the rook is lost at the end
before retreating to 8 quality 5 here
White is already deployed there, and here already
there is no question who is better on
so of course horse services 5th yes
Well, let's say this ending is the king and
well, let everyone then the rook goes out to
operational space through the nose queue is not
looks like it's a big problem of equals
probable gives high probability draw
must be something I don't know can't be changed
owns a rifle 1813 here i think florida 3
I can suddenly take b5 and play and
when someone has someone less often in this
the positions were that maybe at first so
from fix i i step to then would
500 heaps this is 4 tbsp with a double
the tournament of three passers is formed by us
moreover, already ate with his own and went and
6 how we are in general and
and expected and 6 and now we had
problems before after you own with you own and
steve icelanders 7 position did not look
completely equal and in general yes and in general
equal did not converge with us did not converge with
us get an immediate draw here
what is it can how is it possible
it’s more cultured to play with black, of course, and
it is impossible to allow, that is, there is a knight's move
up to 5 maybe but why is it good yes
say speaking for flesh income all the way
before the move beat 7 before near which too
as if there is some kind of equality
inequality
where can be rook 6 yes but but if
it will be very bad, I probably guessed
her nail guide owns ruslana 5 i
I'm afraid under the ligaments I want to replace the faucet and 7
then go with you and then combine
demands yes there will be pleasure immediately
it is very bad to attack the knight c3 here
played deev 175 years later on 1
who has better questions here
arises here better already no one has
better someone has won a pawn too
on the same 7 will be eaten and on the next move
well, yes, as it threatens, it won’t even break everyone
newspaper Kyiv passport subsequent do
from the leaves until the evening put a brick on
wait a second, maybe
central that's what we got back you want
say but it's us belta obviously it's not
yawned he knows the answer so well
wait, well, here it’s all the same today on
7 will come, I'll be a full hundred
fun night villain 5 yes yes ladies what
such a rook casio already here I have a lot of moves
h4 wondering the water h5 wondering you
put the 5th to second h5
I start to come in but I ate because I
greedy ate our 3 yes that's all always
spelled went king [ __ ] 8 ours off
somehow I don’t want to receive on the eighth
a row said hello I don't know I don't know otherwise
I live according to my I just and where in 6 years 6
original gay 6 wearing 6 i didn't see the entrance
owns 6 check exchanged for 8 water to 7
before but we still gave so much
royal city you can from this to
maybe start with this already five
general staff headquarters and in fact
in fact, he is 5 so far, in general, what kind of tattoos
fun and again I want to say about
that against a person whose
hours 1:32
go all in 5 given position
takes a lot of courage again
one of the options yes yes yes yes requires
great courage because the enemy
yours may, on occasion, not
ponder until the end of the party ignored
and it's good if it's a draw at the end
if an objective assessment does not read I
I'll just keep pushing
pressure on the clock in the comments
supports not but you're probably all
make the right moves because
again dekaru nakamura seems to me
refers to the number as from people who in
able to find this state but how would
ready to put yourself in this in this
challenge to go to
the base is true here meeting with the novelty
some unknown transition 9 2
there are two concepts, let's say it is necessary, that is
or somehow guess where to turn
where I'm most likely worse but position
remains playable and fight over the board
either believe in yourself and waste time
and not on the most principled line in
hope that you will find everything, give Qatari
it seems to me that the bark will quite say that
in this and the spiers, I will count everything cleanly
another thing is that you need to believe that there
outcome, as it were, finally and ask nothing
because I don't think anyone
state here at this moment at twenty
second year to her g-100 to the end
count though all myth 5 yes and if not f5
that we still had some attempts
login debit is we were engaged here
those sacks of lemon didn't like me
liked because we do not have time
born before 6 yes, if only they could
relatively speaking go by five icons to 5
on word 5 ponte say king and all
maybe it wouldn't be so bad here
everything is clear how she has a trash I just myself
even that is, well, there is somehow different
gift conditionally king hd king h2
papers 5 so and king and all up to y
whites 2 on one on the royal on what
in fact i don't reduce absolutely no
very nice, even here the position is glad
because I just walk the same king 3 h5
I keep the rook on d1 so as not to pull anywhere
knight e3
I will take her to the wheel area moreover
somewhere at the decisive moment it may still be
so4 bcd 1 articles well, they can do it
blacks pull apart honestly it
I don’t look at anything big with my fingers
I like her less for blacks because
that some kind of direct contours of the grievous
harder mini-factory i don't understand i don't
I understand where black has a counter chance
respectively white will be pretty
for a long time to strengthen your position for free
a coach might actually be needed
walk here already 6 let's say our 4 walk
king e7 try somehow through the f-file
am a deev 8 and wait for move h5 to beat
beat them little 15
but again, this is the position of the next
Black doesn't have a move, in fact they can't even
go again and don't know what gives sooner
all this again to rest topaz
conditional reinforces again a very week
evgenia c4 would whole b1 raising the entrances
small one move crazy totally i
I just needed to pass them on
agitating stages the price will drop to 11 because
what do it not in every women even
this position does not look absolutely equal
food or you can say completely stupid
by the body is only one to support the input
create a checkpoint to weight a 6 by 6 m
right up to the plan is unpretentious and on but completely
not necessarily that
black be easy to deal with so
before
problems by the look of some problems then
yes maybe before try again
then solve them forcibly bus 5
yes, and not 5 on the boat, maybe I can do that
go where 5 while attacked the elephant and
covered the invasion fields vertically
let's say the question is how equal is this
rooker
and the rooker is this question more more
one question at once bandits in 4 yes well
money here it is here given in this fingers
there is some move get along f1 which me
a little embarrassed for the wheel to 7 yea
here is the forger dosey maybe up to maybe
be all right somehow once in
money is no longer so scary
it becomes easier to breathe of course
with black leading to f1 I have to
the feeling is there but I can play
slower i can go there queens 2 or
and fd4 can be vice versa on the other
Is it the same side view
king and everyone feels like this is a side view
on the
yes strange wires yourself
well, besides that, you can still still can
be pondering on the formula 9 6 because
what kai meth 4 maybe we can go
on the next move also say a bishop and 5
there is a rather nasty fork and
so I didn't really understand what
some salon already transition cuffs
it can be pretty scary actually
deed went clothes f1 very much
yes, come on, yes, that is, let's go back
in the water out of 5 maybe even owning 5 already
hastily and where on which field we want
put here I am again h5 nichols very
sensible ideas and on need to have it
reciprocal already
if we leave the rook down, then I will already be
relatively free
because there is a click on 1 to 7
vladimir 6 you might have any idea
go admit already go h4 constantly
same 5 win date somehow and finally
again salon 5 completely cut down the lags
wow by the way but by the way in a second
but I do not have enough moves I wanted
paid money g5 from same king e7 i
rather lose everything after c4 but then again
according to the same scheme c4k or 6504 if
would roughly say sitting here walking
king 2 black go b5 it's fingers
how hopeless
may very well contain d4
very much for 4 I want not God's life is given
ours and yet it is this one
the plan before me is very frightening
think you one pawn for quality and
there on the queen actually still
very, very far from any
be it is meant
curious all this of course not yet
youngest one of whom is already the same too yet
not compelled i can see andy boat 5 you
should start apparently yes i can tell
start again for sure
there are questions
questions yes
and in the five-year plan we raise the question to
the question of Hikaru's attitude towards complex
it is convenient for tasks to combine the two
factors first, he believes that he
able to count the author to you
frankly, we didn't like it either.
depressive scenarios by exchanging on e6
liked the police to send killed 6 to me
he seems to have every reason not to
want them to play so well but also here
curious where the rook will go it's pretty
defining now moment again by
ideas well
and close yet should not begin to think
here I am even at some point already
thought about the move 4 sorry bear
come here pawn and 6 cover and 6 very
it's a pity, yes, but this whole structure
a move slower, well, it’s already quite like that
Karakov Dylan Rook and One Anaconda
5 get out the elephant own 5 went
after all, Lada Masha owns the exit
undoubtedly the most requested
because she is 5 candy 5 yes and taru
instantly 328 guess some income
right now, how interesting it is for us too
actually report in the chat that the computer
own walks them 5 in this position
so I'm sure you think so
either own f5 this rook
which is probably worth a pretty penny
nicer but boring yes and either some
fieri sometimes or need to start
recognize all pawns except pawn and 6 as
ta yes ta yes well, that is, retreat like an elephant
on the taking of knives let's choose the field
if you really need to consider this extravaganza
choose a field to start, I understand
that he must control the square g5 everything
equal to let's say suppose on m1 no longer
know why on c1
Well, finally, yes, I don’t know why, but
here removed as far as possible from sin
let's say it here
among other things, it means the outcome
swimming pool b5 me too I thought about it too
up to the horse on d5 so that you don’t drive anymore
from there, while white, as it were, what
going on the same mode on their own what
there is a good question here h4
there is a completely crazy hots 34
giving up the whole kingside for
some pace illusory don't know what
these rates give to be honest I'm so easy
24 but not quite because most likely
as many as 4 pieces need to be saved until needed
save print like this
factor yes yes yes and everything is in a glass and nice
elephant on the same 5th already think well, and we
Let's just say we'll try one exchange
allow water up to 8 aka 5516
alla grandfathers 6 in general before
and even if not at 6 did not quite understand firmly
you start the movie badly yes on the pawn bye
filled with i like the idea of ​​a big pawn
she sent their grandfather one threatens us h5
as if to eat
relentlessly with problems well so yeah
cells for laden and did not interfere very much
here are some amazing fingers
which, if not, cannot attack again
on a pawn and 6 before it looks like if
save the rook I see no other way
save la diodes fingers other than the horse's move
up to 5 of 6
then I had to do
previous moves here knight f6 yes
it's just obviously a stronger case
goes and go they are stronger that at 18 h5 a
before quarreling it I flow them deviating
prompted clothes 6 get along yes and 1 and
now now they have harbors in
six and we probably want knight h7
engage in smoking out his comrade sg5
you damn insane positions positions
absolutely bad start insane position
but we at least you know we announced that
we are all pawns one white without one color
just in case, count and no no I
no all the pawns we gave away when we 11 4
to 6 5 step it's calvary to another
previous next this did not apply otherwise
she's still relatively sane
these are the Martian landscapes but with
point of view of maximum gravity
when habitual yes in terms
material ratio total 1
stylishly further well, what do you think until your
the count is a little wonder what he's up to
still not done because again
wet confirm only this is central
line after after 6 there is a choice is possible
this often happens yes that's all you have
look but to the bottom option to believe
that white wins at the end of this
computer analysis difficult modern
practice is just the opposite.
confirms that most likely if both
play correctly in what kind of
forced variations is a draw and
probably killed now there are two options with
trying to check yes somehow well yes and on
in fact, of course, very turning
moment because owns it again
such
like a game for micro advantage and which
we proceed from the fact that probably the rook
hodgepodge with an equal number of goal pawns
should not win, although of course they have
initially nicer rooks more active there
the majority on the royal is more significant
than most blacks on the queen and
there is all this madness
pawn drops starting now
immediately slando 2 slates one they
stronger again
that is, the fork is so pretty
essential here between these new
decisions
yes, well, where 3 do you want to heat the cheater, well then
there are 3 trails possible in this direction but I don't
I see absolutely no point now
openly give the polar boat say
now after the same already four already out
king e7 why why did we release
released the blackness operational freedom
or even say you can spend the pace on
b5 on chance in district 7 shortened
ride 4 too
funny as it is nowhere
absolutely a platoon is neither 6 here I am
thought h5 go as much as 5 layers 4 date rush
there is still alive such will fix g8 i
want to beat drink go elephant same 5th
6 people will leave
roles 7 lampada i was waiting still tinkering
maybe i'm really nothing
achieved training better as it were quite
a possible outcome of such options but but
regardless and yes yes yes yes it's one for
others not connected took knives 7
5 villains seem to be almost zero
you hold and began to hold 6 but in fact
this is where it all started
and the model, well, apparently somehow we walk 15
and we hope that we did not lose, but well,
didn't win
painfully seeing to master I'm just
mistake, we must see the king, but we can’t
let's go white
and you didn’t send it, but you probably have it
then king e-8 daikon q1 what are you not
it was also where to jump
yea yea than the astoundingness of the tire
of course we won’t be strong on positions
get involved because we want and dima
will now be made on ladies very
delete
but very far away from all this and
compete with a person who is more
in total it's all well watched with kent
allamagi with centaur we don't want here
try to fight with recursive
centaur
one more time let's talk about that
let's run like the sun, although there is one
ferret beats three because one more time
we will repeat tode then we will reach everything
owns only always has a rook loop move
6th answers scientists suddenly just
at the ready big therefore on whom it beats
you whites should do some other
I don’t even know the move, bringing f1 maybe it’s necessary
three if you don't want, well, I don't know, they beat the water and at 5
for you so sorry 5 of course that is
this seems to be the correct solution, but again
the same based on the fact that m belta is aware but
in terms of madness on the board we
of course rooted for some other move for
gambit food for gambit i start owns 5
here we were discussing what is black
gotta beat on period wires don't take on
f4 this position feels very
dangerous not messing around 4 very strong
threatened dev1ce tone in general why
create this time on the flank of you
while dropping an elephant to the enemy
looks strange horse yeah you look
countries again such a petty tactician
which it is not harmful to show from the educational
they want to change their minds and change the elephant for them
this will not be given here, because in
the end of this variation, the rook is just behind
the score is defended by a pawn yes I think so
hikaru should be in this position
naturally should be on and gesture this
pawn alive and who would look strange
well here is the question
how exactly here white should yes and if
develop some
at the moment you can probably do it for now
some gender can king h2
in order to move on the king e7
logged f1 and claim we won
tempe, well, I can play water until 8 on
well, there was a question after all, maybe
maybe this one is worse than scientists, but with
given that I can't get out
pawn quite right and such
damn fair remark wait a second
why because remote entrance
and yet it is not created there
sushi is still smashed what the tour's about
what do you say if we consider such a me
went and and past to the turn of the storm otherwise
Starting Minsk Court 4 To Don't Her
fixed scene like 5 you again
again and 4
otherwise, the face of 4444 workshop, I have it in this
moment will be a king in the center on 4 well
yes, with b4, that is, roughly speaking schematically
and if the whites walk there, here's honey back this one
pawn b still leaking queens
given here is the moment white will have the king and in
June and that they just beat and second themselves
tarot yes but but but the king actually
of course it will not be necessary to go ahead and
White then creates a passed pawn on
on the kingside deceive the king
and win peshich without giving, as it were, all of these
recipes do you know bungalow parties
lasker see long known hotel prices
on therefore
owning sept you can't walk but maybe
you can just go here but also I'm not up to
the end I understand can white trick such
rook or not don't know five or six
some of these moves
I'll rush the same until before except this is
there is a question there is the sharpest yes yes
can snouts took yes there conditionally who
wins like this owning you like this
ricky white naveen
but the pawns are too close and rather white
Feeling yes, that is, regardless of
the fact that blacks have 4 whites 2 hectares regardless
na na na strong material
concessions pawn same fear combination yet
I can’t cut off the eighth row
arrow and light again
I like the king cut off yeah well here I am
I wanted to cut it off with an arrow, well, then
it is clear that this position is difficult
probably just lost most likely
it's holding up so daddy
from experience, such positions are a wreck, but
what is really there on
a few moves back with either 6 or
live five more such sent what
I would like to create something
the checkpoint is already but there are three in short
villains 3 shah jene omc
at least not immediately ripe 3
although again, here is such a first sign on
so mad that is white then has time
play shorter thriller 4 well, that's too
let's say took took and drove his 5 king
g3
there is a move king e4 but this is most likely
slow so this uncle can c4 you
I can still sweat and summer I don't have anyone
dries up and by the way c4 just shoots
apparently the checkpoint danik at the checkpoint already
Won't and until I'm 68 moves on it
spend a6 c5 yes yes yes yes a6 c5 c6
real because if again there and already
do not invite me to play c50 myself
something here here she's almost here we're already
let's go and 4 date maybe ashes is us
it is not created after take place 4 yes and
and this is actually important at all, and the second
the moment is certainly not the king g3 h4
right away I want well this is also 4 the same five
sweets already such yes count owns 300
ths start will have to go somehow 94
white vintage 4 fault the cut too
may actually be
may already have had 12 to walk on
the seller why take the c-pawn which
not much help mined well yes maybe
turn out to be really wrong
nice even this lazy ending
everything is simple and we are even bored
could become
in fact, even this may be
no i wouldn't that i miss you
sugar, I'm rather in now, as it were,
I'm trying not to show it but
my inner feelings are monstrous
absolutely because I'm ready
morally for the next two or two hours
half wrong about every
word
your money but complex complex and sharp
lodeynoe yes we will be silent do not count
I offer options, yes, but it’s like with
point of view is not a method of good
television let's say if you count us
tv up good tv
usually requires video requires not only
pictures and sound yes that's making sounds in
such on spiers is extremely difficult
to publish you is not difficult here
meaningful and at the same time olga
it doesn't look meaningful
a perfect idiot, but we kind of again
people are familiar and look so
apparently not the first day and you are so
apparently this is not a simple rooker
Hikaru hasn't taken on f4 yet, so what?
it seemed to us completely automatic
Yes, I'm thinking what other moves besides
rooks 6 knights in 4 you can inspect
com beats 3 i cant believe it
there combi trilogy one is not easy yet
an attempt to immediately lose the guys to the water
up to 7 is it possible up to 7 but well, I didn’t want to
her 2 step to allow but maybe
we own up to 7 it no longer has any
meaning horse barely there went to role in 2
took so what this year and here
cute moment what is this yes this
it is possible to apply cribs and
tactical strike stranger then this
madness
The king has seven too, so it feels
it's an attempt to try to lose
forced game
this is 4 we then another 4 we will add yes
it's like if black immediately and not
surrender this miracle what for the sake of swtor it is necessary
firstly, if you didn’t give up right away, date you
you play tass the same one, this is the real one
endgame with bishop against knight before
potential passer killed by a sharp
flank not on horseback in 4 must play
no, well, it’s still issued here actually
plays except 3 4 rows say that choice
between horses 4 elodea 6 but don't own
monstrously dislike this nickname 4 Dec 4
a pawn will be beaten nov 6
and now there will be a question to the maxim
the ship is yes yes exactly how it is
going to develop here
initiative
here even at some point visited me
thought maybe you know maybe
try to give away on the same sempre 4 rooks
but something is hard to believe, but it is
very responsible decision
you understand naturally, that is, here is the camp
f1 until we have our latest version
each I left, and even the last that we
watched walked king steering wheel h2 wait
until the black ourselves inform important on
really what was our Lord
leave
if I give up a pawn with a check, then I
now and now the king has a seven idea
walk owns f1 and insists on too
except for the king until 71, nothing will happen to me
chest d6
Well and there no one sense the same thing I don't
I think that he is better not for women
I usually live there at 76 rooks, but here I am
they give you wait, although grandfathers have already given 6
one king c5 and nobiletin played for everyone
would 5 like her in terms of galdi
for a draw, anish, that is, somehow everything is
elk culture is absolutely sagalova
the active king will now come out 2 rook and
we will actually start to pile up these
these are the famous weaknesses
weaknesses on the queenside
maybe on maybe actually
very certainly thin spiers already the first
the move in this position is not so easy to guess
and of course gives a great head start in such
subconsciousness of at least the following three
moves for any side and rather it
applies of course maxim nick
no hikaru who has already spent 40 minutes
on some decided as a person
actually really white
as many ways can you rook f1 to wield
d4 supplied pf pouting maybe possible
just cause rooks play walk here
we stand here another move shorter steering wheel
or or h4 or kings autovo why
I don't like the cow I want
grandfather wanted to raise a speech about it
institute here just want 4 how much
this is quite so and mother and not just
I will continue waiting for deev eight now and
I don't really want to take it
you can give them deev 6 but ke beat on f6
it can get along 8 hp g6 somehow and even and
here if I took the same 6 let's say and gave
you now mine one terrible choice
you will understand the date, whether you are going to a position with
cut off by the king to the wrong place I don't want to
completely i ran ahead i think 6
received from I get to eat utensils mata
no but it looks pretty weird
Tied up wore a king get it bye
perpetual check right here
drove the king and say let's go the king
3 floor some confidence somewhere not
so stupid as they won't be already fine enough
active went to whether it is permissible to keep 6
I don’t know how it is in 4 refrigerators
this pawn passes with the help of the king on
must somehow even 50 ate one until before
6 ate our second second so far
bent one from behind but she put
hold 5 to
first power bi yawned summer rook
sometimes not, but again, this recipe is
what then when 7 regular therefore not
we will get carried away but we are all
showing to say what if
actually the sharpest he seems can
be just a rookie
five pawns each two rooks actually
the configuration is precisely this weakness
offensively both flanks with potentially
dangerous majority
on royal for whites and no no
wealthy kings potentially
just an action movie but a lot of course
depends on which drawing.
here Maxim will choose as much as he wants
play rooks on the board
and so on, therefore it is important and very
the decision now he has to promise
Petra does not call us to account
they ask how much all the same in the hall
calculation to weak we have minus 40
hit 45 I have glamor it seems to me or
42 did something like that but only there
in about six life attempts therefore
somewhat restricts my
achievement in this field lack of
me and if someone listens to me from
I don't ask for this manual
you free account is not an attempt
how to complain about the lack of buns
I don’t have and I don’t have a planned end
the firstfruits therefore, as it were, one puzzle every
day that is you do one called
birth, I think I made one of everything
well, I chose 40 reassured you need that is
forty forty is enough, it’s clear that, as it were
like any other muscle, this muscle needs
train with constant repetitions
perplexed by constantly repeated with the other
hand I think just three times
made them in a row, that is, in one of them
huge in the address of attempts you will come across
no, I can't take it easy and serious
positions broken down into results can be
a lot but i again i'm v-shaped
exercising in the morning we come to them we
we come to conditionally speaking to studio 7
trophy starts at 8 and usually this one
at least one hour between seven and eight
one run on a large tonnage
the screen that we have in the dressing room
we try but there is a problem that
if you stand too far from the account
you can see the whole screen but you can't reach it with your hands
will give, as it were, not to make a move, but if you stand up
close enough to be easy to move with your fingers
on
then you don’t see on the glass, let’s say
the last times yes yes you do not see
the last row and get a little lost
understanding of what I ask from you
problems so to speak therefore it is such
additional challenge yes like a puzzle
puzzle horn you see 7 8 chalkboard
baggy big screen
they let's hashtag #dyh
but somehow still thinks
thinking to everyone's surprise yes that is and
here, apparently, I know something
assumed he knew something
strange if I don't know so because it is
again, we already had confirmation in
chat that's the first line in at least
Least after horse and 7 and lice and 6 is the first
line
computers in 5 but as if up to 5 undoubtedly
should be after the same 4 already
considered if we come back again
if we go back to how it all
happened before here
bill blitz val that he's up to 5 no doubt
there one of there first three moves
that come to mind maybe
even the first move that comes in
head 4 like 494 horses 7 and very
It is logical to recall again that
immediate horse and 7 offered by evgeny
cavalry 5 victory is simply torn apart very
dangerous in the forest of blacks immediately
becomes well and beaten beaten and 6 and 5 and
5 main move owning 5 gta 5 it all
very logical therefore
took away yes here we are already more or less
described alternatives yes that is and well yes
according to the meaning of this egg pfs double win
I mean it must be a finger
pretty good let's see the maximum so
that such an interesting pause is not not very
it is clear why there is a pause here
refreshes the mind
pictures because it is clear what is here
probably a lot of similar similar
order of moves that differ
some kind of meme for the details and need
try to remember exactly what
of the possibilities the most-most clearly
buy so we until now we
considered the development of pipes doubling in d
and somehow quietly moves the king king
lion 2 king g2 were attempts
Yes, except for some I'm forcing cabbage soup
there are pancake moves, yes dad is like that too
standard school idea to step up
king since with the king on the same one
white just like an elephant will not be sold here
Yes, wait, but by the way, the transition to one
bad ending if its all the same
perform water fd4 we said it
the king same us stopped up
chess seven rooks and 7 now take
on and 7 and say slowly walk to go
king 2
that now owns the university is not particularly
effective yes she don't understand what and
covered up new depots which are usually black
overwritten the contour yes yes but here is the question
can be black of course can be adjusted
run b5 c5 again and although the score then
create some try walkthroughs
on the queen besides this but again
nerves gives you it full social
culture I asked myself the question I can't
do i go same 5 fret h8 but probably
allow rooks fadin f5 and move into
such a parterre is not an occupation for everyone
taste
we need the king cut off yes and can't
be a very tangled spire in which
of course on the fly to navigate extremely
difficult
yes and so and here and water but water tf1
still self up straight model tf1 most
begging king to 7 wife and length
hikaru but it didn’t have anything else
him special pick up rent what's how
would pawn black move right not
have it that's why most likely
just hopeless especially with king d 8
so the king to 700 is essentially forced
yes now what we tried actually
rook gave everyone ideas 7 took took and how
we have been returning to this position for a long time
then why did you own all the plays yeah that's
I and families with this can not yet beat on
and this one may be there
any sense to do such 1 month
narrow pause until go king same 2
for example exactly here yes like like version
like the version on the boat, here I am and 8 let's say
homemade shields pancakes 8 you know what husband
here shox d 1 a
by the way, it's funny, yes, because the king
have to go connected 8 yes and here
still the king I 6 change and everyone there like
do not hit
well, now we'll go then yes or
period 4 legs the truth here resets
absolutely the entire queenside, although it can
be we and under the howl is not strong, strong
worries let's say to the role in the c 2 h trilogy
5 heroes 4 houses Crimea such a role in 4 to
such a futurama we want to want to come to us
on the same 6 it's easy to win and it's not so for us
it matters how much we gave to the farm
yes, the idea of ​​white is naturally not to move
pawns create one pass let
black give the owner here to go to the feet
king well, yes, given that fail
8 probably just won't be back in the game
already in this party yes we want we want
greedily collect one Tuve well done again
they have to walk yes well and that's the question
here maybe 1 can have a gun
one is enough
it's 6 on occasion monstrous can like
threat sooner or more there rook move
h1 can h1 naturally on occasion
I own we will pick up 6 went to my grandfather 8 and now
we must count by an inch and we will undoubtedly eat
on black for that time will create took on
move before the cockroaches will run there
huge numbers in this country
again a cockroach but instantly yes I can’t
get rid of the thought of cockroaches thinks
maxim really 2 same two looks
this is my own and the dragon is quite
looks silly income king 2 yes bye
here or maybe h3 h4 even with the fact that
even 4 just started what I will punish conceived
maybe they can catalog again
already 8 king 3 didn’t even achieve anything
5 after all, it looks like he doesn’t really want to
give me it seems especially given i was walking
already on f1 same 5 owns 5 clothes 8 is
this is the most under passive
approach here htr h4 he plays think that
not so much in order to compete with
he is 5 how many, as it were, without determining
until which cell will the king go well
there is such a waiting struggle available
the name is an idea
White then the exchange of one pair of rooks and
king cut off from potential 1 on in
features here you can not walk while owning 8
because in the same position we are also
pawns not immediately ship f2 will be king and
halved amounted to no communication yes we
there for 94 the lion king 3d we will force
you can sweat there in 5 moves to pick up
pawn
well that is not at 5 yea pick it up to
this is clearly here we did not have time to cut on
5 and most likely such and such police as
men can't save black anymore 5 start again
I don't like the idea though
take
take all
sharp flank I want to take everything
pieces and pawns
potentially very dangerous. yes which
we declared somehow initially yes everything
it's interesting, but it seems to me
lemonade its boring is somewhere boring
no equal well, well, so they said that
it's a pity that the transition of the rooker is most likely everything
gotta hold on he can be and
holding on really but I'm still
it's a pity because in those stations in
tourist then there in the first
tourist because much easier to count
in a vehement sense, I, as it were, well, it’s clear what it is
the fish is looking for where it is deeper, and I wanted to have
position in which I could demonstrate
understanding how my horse walks
cognac they ale ale catch up with the day I already
I don't know what these figures are now
that's why it's as good as taking your legs away
until we know our message
know b5 again again
in some confusion
give a pretty nasty it seems worth it
task before hikaru who
well, that is, for good, I still have nothing
he could on occasion and 40 minutes already
give a head start on the clock but m belta is
for some time
testing your knowledge up to but even even 20
minutes of such a position is a decent margin
because well, yes, that is, as it were, here
very complex drank black to become anyone in
in the sense that when finds happen
extremely large but not very
it is clear how to count it with a finger and
so you are in this
in this position when you don't know
what do I need to stop and
choose a move, that is, if you try
really find the best Croatians to go
maybe 40 minutes of class because
all these fingers merge into one and you need
somehow not typing is not very clear how
indeed, there is a short account here
not work on you need to somehow count
these endings with the running of those very
cockroaches date days run white pawns on
royal black what's there to eat at
queen and it seems that he has
almost an hour for 13 rows now but on
actually
it's not as much as it could be
introduce themselves from afar and plus it's like that
very how to say depressing
unpleasant account because no end
the edge is not visible to him, that is, you counted
somewhere in some way you can move
that seems to be like the lower draw yes that's it
it's like you start yourself
check recheck yes what else what
ideas or, roughly speaking, by weight
choose some solution say here
should be comfortable enough and went and
tell myself that I don't care until the end
I'll figure it out during the new I'm talking during
all poses
that time will still be useful to me when we
let's get to some more specific
questions to finally something will be possible
count relatively some short
an account will be required and there in this
mode go here or be 5 or king and
6 to force beat applying less
some kind of poison solution pleasing actively
between themselves
tried to imagine if it was possible to drink
il-18 h5 same 6 but can't take the answer
the answer is not most likely the most clear
describe this idea imagine that
blacks of their own free will for some reason go to
I don't rub this position, I think it's bad
absolutely protected
this is probably not the only years after
which scientists are bad in this option but
the most obvious case has not yet been given
even our perk and 6 because they defended
naturally the rook is lost just to take
and that's why black with you hands hastened
creating a checkpoint on when you're mannheim
when you play on same 6 white will get
exactly what you need, you can go to
some pawn after took took black
sieve take away the f7-pawn, but how could they
take away are published
more or less therefore the decision frankly
not good, but this is the question of
what comes to my mind when i
I'm trying to put myself in that position.
for black I immediately somehow try
before jumping off I'll say then narrow
fast paced sti reduce to
known tasks are directed to what
reduction to test tasks or most likely
leads because the party of Ukraine
if if artificially create some
short bill over he might turn out
very very unpleasant date he apparently
bring let's play let's say I'm king
6 so that this does not already loomed
bundle
this one went probably the king 2 for sure
talila don't know what's available at turn 20
let's move that's black suppose
they play something on the queenside
it seems now I don't understand how to behave
through to 8 comes to here b5 again
suppose doctrine c5
maybe as it should
organize the dismount of the presence came from 4
for example, I don’t know if it’s necessary, no, or no, well
tried to go c4 c4
choose how you want life we ​​are not I
I think it may be necessary here already in
breakaway and go try noticeably
busy going behind the root
after which b will seriously queen you
already done and yes how are you on the same 5 that we
we are going to do on the water up to 26 and even
ohhey, there are shishi, tree-sticks, everything is very
ill share 2 all passed yeah just
did not have time here, that is, here is the fact that
the king is cut off and just won't have time like that
that is, for 4 to be and you offered
combined 6 but I don’t understand what we are
we want from 14 to but you still pass
the same 5 before the hearths or yes that is c3 apparently
worth playing to
that she would 4 same go stop this
the process is impossible, yes, here you can
there is a move, they seem to read one too
here I’ll prove it more or less
let's not sit down 4 let's go out
just the same 5 stands, which is probably literacy
actually what tour is the same
thing you can play on b4 now
play from a to z anyway black
must move a4 here is the idea that the pawn
hell and a rook behind here
and maybe this is enough by the way because
which is most likely
how it will end on this pawn you need
will distract entered yes no sketchy
king 4 b4 beat everyone
and b3 and most likely you will have to dig a6
and they will collect, roughly speaking, they will change here
these are these three
exchanged for a pawn and would remain 427
and which draw position let's say
schematically it looks like some
reasonable try for black but understandable
what if somewhere we have something along the way
it’s not difficult, but literally even in this
positions it might turn out to be that question
one pace
on 62 h7 azhazha by steve and everyone is thirsty
if I smoldered for years on words even shoshanna
h7 h7 but now you put black with 8
exactly in time for the road dremel otherwise
otherwise king g5 king 6 most likely
end just if black do some
move olya king and 6 you most likely
lose 5 to most likely lost
because we will have time for the king until 5
go rook 1 and pose a threat laden was
equally she is a pawn, whatever you give the king
wife hand in hand internet party ending
that is, everything is really extraordinary
counting sleeping in which these are all
the boons of stupidity such as proper creation
they are all of little importance
have
yes it's all good there us sculptures
the game hasn't had great ratings for a long time
in books 50 compensation with circuit play in
this position black has no right to go
because she is dangerous how next yes
now everything is hard move entrance
dangerous position what to say
and well, you know, we have never
somehow managed to change the character of this
yes, no matter how much they tried
it will always be this rook in
in which the question is whether the blacks have time
run somehow on the queen against one
pawns same or pawn h given against
royal flank pass and not that
there is like
if again try to understand between what
and than the choice of king i 6 probably whole
pace whole pace but clear clarity
clarity I love clarity if not
want such instant clarity it
apparently you need to start pushing immediately
swap pawns or would 5 yes because
meaning under pancakes h8 offhand I can't
call a rook except on e-8 we
moved it only helped white cut-off
roleplaying on i feel very good
losing error simply because
clothes one step repeat it again
a very important motive, but his year is, as it were, his
you need to remember you can’t even go to role 6
she loved growth changing than you didn't
you beat anyway, the figures remain
on line e you have to go to feed 8
mm and then volume bilham king and halve
all the same studs still
exacerbated for black by the fact that the king
cut off along line d and back no longer
will return to belov distant polyne h
will be in the near future
vladi the only meaningful one
the move is the rook it was going on, again, why are we
prepare h5 yes we don't get and
we adjust the pawn of our 5-ku given itself
general don't mind go it's unclear
except that here we want to go rook 6
this position and whether the store is the same 60 we
want water hd 6 let's say cargo g26
here again we improve or worsen
my position my know-how above lenovo
rather worsened
for walking the queen of the flank you didn’t go, but
it is, and now some kind of frontal
demonstrate an attack to the rook
same 8 to exchange there a couple okay king
lion 4 walk and give viz
That's exactly what I'm talking about, but I'm also not sure.
owners 5 don't yell you're already there
I'm coming, it's good
yes just you say starting with the move
fritters 5 if we voluminous in 7 interpret
will hide under the Ladino umbrella and
everyone no no he pancakes 8 check and if
boat crosses this sense in odessa
tongue camelina pawn and also cod and
some kind of pumpkin cake for us
positions
I think that they just have to be
hopeless or close to where I am
time step zhsk before 5 took away and all and
so I can manage to f8 and I will switch from
I'll cross over from Yemen, you'll take it and eat it
economy mind with them easement not
Enough pace no doubt u have problems well
which is actually confirmed by the fact that
these are good to thinks time minutes before
it's better to ask about my before
speech about the fact that 58 minutes is not so
many 10 minutes have already been spent and there
listened to diash 8 to 6 rook yes h5
rook 6 king how did 25 come out
im they proudly considering that
console on the boat 6 drove already ours
let's go selling deo 33 4 shorter than four
get along 36 or vice versa on
we simply bet that it will pass in
perfect in appearance
or by the way I want to say in this
a specific position is pretty good
looks like everyone took it and the same tin from me
their will be two owners two camps all
shop here the number of pawns actually them
there will be two of them, although there are some steps
from the bottom start don't know how much it
right i think it can be up to 63
it will be cleaner
although also on hand well 2 connected rook
ahead of you until the king is not really then
7 waiting life voyage 8 this is the ones myself
yes yes yes and u gave birth before the term
self-propelled guns, but it’s applicable here
self-propelled pawns are absolutely true
it's true, it could be
really need clenched teeth
start a game immediately
the queen was rolled out again and hope that
that's enough
because in one of our
options we managed black mustache count
actually here is probably your
these famous arrows 5 will come in handy before
play again a 4 c5 yes c5 and rush
b4 on such and such floating I own
behind the checkpoint bags and we are trying
namely to drop a pawn on d4 without giving
would be 44 in most cases just like that
to catch up with pawn a to 4 then c5 b4
give up a pawn on b4 create a passed pawn on
3 and hope it's enough
distraction to
make some draw without without checkers
most likely, whites will answer
undoubtedly drive your own there already 5 probably
together open will go up all the same without
the king's difficulty of beskar, let's say so
if h5 is again 5 then that's the feeling
what did serious on sherlock our 8 to
made a serious mistake and
case even look for no chapuzhi on
sad fight yes of course in this pc
I want at least the same king 4 but we
did not secure the rear and continue until
wait wait for the decision is about hikaru
nakamura in this hospital continue
wait for a winning game in London
so bad not so bad by the way u
US
chances specifically at the moment to me
it seems that
and because it's funny yesterday here
they asked what adam would do and
Indeed, we recall once again that
the same scene you now here's a view of
the board will actually show a more general
view of the stage there are still playing two parts
final and match for third place in
championship
british championship knockout there
yesterday also two draws
yes, it’s true, and by the way, it’s naive
semi-finals, too, it seems to me almost
Armageddon played some murakumo edge
please no
cities to the conservatory definitely
something needs to be changed by my husband we
so this is the most circles we go a little bit
ideas are over, well, something is difficult at all
new about this position said on
surely we can continue
show all the same options and
to improve them, as it were, to clear them of some
husks
look for some small details but
of course I would like to see the move because
that on occasion it determines a lot to
here is the solution to
hikaru hikaru on this particular move will be
clearer on what he's trying to aim at
Hikaru remind me was noted several times
here losing such lazy endings
who didn't have to lose yeah well
it's hard not to remember from defeat from
magnus in
here is a very fresh grand tour in
St. Louis in the last even the last
tour that seemed to be absolutely
safe rooker but but still there
position was different in that it was
let's say demand some kind of passive
cleaned up here in terms of standing and neat
repel some threats to fight
potential plan here is all enough
straight up and black yet looks like I'm everything
more inclined towards the idea of ​​organizing
counterplay sb5 again somehow there and now
what what but karos state like this
things on the account without a doubt
yes, actually yesterday, that's how
felt that now something
happen not then first threw it
confident enough
this is basically the theme of this tournament
because before that im viel spass two
such positions against Levon Aronian and in
semi-finals first with white discarding
qualities in the fingers that could
somehow defend passively but there in
it would be very nasty positions
correctly assessed the situation
the quality made the draw comfortable and
in the second installment too, and if someone
remembers in English whether he started there
got a very nice cape and well
how much for a short time of 15 minutes
about 15 moves also took absolutely
correct and practical
decision to give away a healthy central pawn
for exchanging horses and receiving
the rooker quite confidently kept
that at this level the concept is something
reset and defend you put 8 up and
defend the resulting positions there here
surprises with so you wait ka sing h5 same 6
let's see your bad move, I need to
wait for the move here he is supposed to think not
should h5 here is strictly the only one
get it right hikaru thought i
just on g6 rook 6 get along 4 here
it did not live up to 416 for example
enemies 6 so as many as 40 for you can start
this is exactly what it can't be
accidentally field down the rays stank the idea
here again 4 we go back to
claim that this is some kind of repetition
yes, yes, this is complete nonsense
on u all king same 2 u came
actually because of what, although we are we
discussed what I really like
such a billion
than I'm not even sure why I hit on
the system is again for reasons
the very same you are probably white
something else can be squeezed out of the situation
Ladino and all the blacks themselves beat on everything
doesn’t want to, I’m thinking it’s impossible
win by boost here card over
then . my fingers live now do not hang
on i all so on before appears
master up to 4 check and on the king and 8 i lo
trying hard to find some
tactics in which I would eat a rook but
until I find it or I can say start
same seed keeps 6 go get along till 4 step
and now the king and 8 is no longer possible, but there is
iron controller
I don't see how to refute it
extremely thin of course such
black game
yes, well, actually, in my opinion, from this
worth giving up just because
the most mentioned king is already 2 yes yes yes
how come 2 king same three roles 8 go
king e-8 i.e. such forces and
I really like this idea and don't
king and 8 feel like he's coming on
this very position with the offensive
the gradual advance of white on
royal at the same time still losing the whale
the pace is very strange taking away h8 then talking
to put it mildly strange for some reason do not drive
on me a very strange decision to me
honestly i don't like it i don't understand
why not just drop in don't win
so by weight this is a worsened version of everything
that we tried to make a move king
e6 yes but then again if not but I don't even
I understand how to remove them successfully good luck too
if 6 is here then white is good
can still go for serge's flanks
additionally as a god
this position looks like
hopeless belov the best on that sleep and on
that flank on
in fact, what are the grounds for
Chernoluch therefore it is necessary to take into account
do something even slower
and slelat if we are now leaving the gap
then but we have so much tempus burned us
there should never be enough time for
water up to 8 minutes, well, this one actually
position which I said that black is in
pure lost pace cause she
again which, to put it mildly, is not harmful
white king of 4 mountain g5 by famous
samples it feels quite right here even
it’s even somehow funny to talk about pawn
racing no graphics loved them go
in black while there they are on c6
greek advanced on foot by weight rake
it must be completely hopeless
getting along 3 cakes 6 rook
no, they probably punished what will show us
ideas
I don't believe that somehow get along 4 let's go
wished all chess edison sounds well
even 5 water the same 4 now i led the gums off
I got by somehow after the king u-6
contain 3 same 5 king and 6 here I don't
could find a clear way to win immediately
but she keeps and naturally whites walk
own 4th place and business to the same 5th place
but these two will run it because they
already so close to the transformation fields
there is no game here especially this
amazing story happens because
that honestly feeling that one out on it
one of the worst edits we have
saw this lodey this is possession
when we saw maybe
the idea is to put the rook here
need 5 and not let the king on the same 5
force white to go the same 5 create
one checkpoint instead of two honestly
saying how white this fact will be
saddened so still again 6 water and all
and where are the aisles try try for
start eating them looking for them yet while I immediately
no one will give yes yes here
Undoubtedly getting younger comes tearing up
maybe something like this put on the same 5
4 checks converge, but there is also shorter 6
this type of suturing in general in general
I don't understand anything of this life 6 from the same as
he is already anesthetized to speak equality write
we will have to comment on this from
refuse to evaluate hopeless cases
good why is this a question
furthermore, who knocks ryan yes no
I know if this is such a position I would like
specify which one exactly because they
not always right in such an ass one of them
endings even from maternity endings
because let's say if it if such on
some site on the site then there depths it
gaining not so fast to clearly
evaluate such a steeple what we are
have already returned, I honestly say in principle
I don't understand, you don't see how it can
be supportive of this joke on
leisure to take this farm is nothing
understood say axim thinks as they said
on this occasion koloboks
I don't understand anything, well, that's good
took 6 knives to pick up then they need hope
898 must be absolutely hopeless well
well, we didn’t even have time to start the pawn
create your own besides yes you probably
can in terms of moved 10 can
come here and ask where and brave
where is this your writing empty say yes
I don't want a won pawn I want to
win the same military that I
dinner then just why earlier come on
water do not live well, let's wait for the move
because honestly i took the nasal passage i
not ready to talk about it
akairo position i wont see hikaru dream
roxanne
let's do it differently, let's offer me
banggood me in the ear zhurbin he me
offered to take a break
anyway, no, I'll have to wait for them
in the course of poetry you will wait for the hadith from
maxim then from hikaru will suffer punishment
think will not go the same 6
think about it after that, it's like, well, well
what's the range for the magic word
break we still leave you for minutes
ten well even if it's a position somehow
magically tied for
next minutes 10 15 days not played
will play so we will definitely be back
yes yes now let's take a little break
stay with us
maybe that's the same nobody's curse
be shattered tonight
[music]
official video station an hour a lass
flash
most
hour
we are now
les enfants
like the world
warehouse
from world of tanks and world of oxford
oxford and wicked games design
exhibitions in man play music in a goal
is to watch as a love train is leaving
become a left tiny love me up and
overalls now we are with you my motorcycle with
whom from conversations with hale parties
they are everywhere their rights to the vatican us in
blues fight
autolady kissed the deck i'm the manager
worth the rent with every music babe plus
distant is ours but plus mezim is right
stop exactly on you and blueberry caught
decal mask blues drop computers
[music]
from the hall language controversy
the world of tanks
game explorer
he is already in a taxi class 2 art florida
the towel hour in footman mayn yell
expenses
[music]
back dear friends as he says
famous classic quote lodeinoe
endings are never won
never win here and we don't
coming any minute let's move on to
explaining why, in particular, everything
what have i said in the last five minutes
absolutely wrong I warned that
so be it but nevertheless here you are
position on the board and we showed you all
this line and I announced 500 we missed
Yes I yawned under la keep her same 5 and I
so in general enthusiastically spoke about
the fact that whites are the best on the royal and on
queened and actually actually
once again we will not see the implementation
the same strategic idea
passively defend no one on such
level does not like and does not want and black
dropped none even two pawns so far
1 has already been given and 2 will be given to myself
next moment to
step up rook rook will go irina
loop c5 will create permanent
threats against White's queenside and
most likely black probably should this
fingers
keep also in this regard you know me
the move of the rook is not fully understood by everyone
was it possible to try in this position
all the same here to move by the king of the same
3 owns 5 or maybe even a king
or river cast here is the king of 4 me here
confuses I know that check and rook h2 and now
here we have the king the king is not serious
less often this king this very long this
construction it passes if absolutely
no on the queen on the king there is a king and
in 4 rook 6 and 100 same yes
when he to actually really then
there is to ensure a pawn
have to king 5 again ite sometimes
it's too long yea again
now we will return to
lighting that possession like a man of honor
I must say that I promised I must
because any minute it starts
last day in philadelphia announced
minutes camera animal good luck dripped
and crane
in the upcoming final dreamhack to the corner
cde cleaning m crane apparently it's like that
gotta keep it gotta keep away
opposition what's on the board since something else
easier because one factor disappeared
important that black's king was cut off by
lazy could not help how to deal with
a German woman in a fight with a pawn, but now what
happens, well, let's say, but according to sensations
don't beat the pool
it doesn't work i.e. you can try
somehow immediately drive a pawn forward to us
here get along 5 here is a completely different situation
because black is not not just something
began to collect on the queen
and also killed only one checkpoint and
the king pretty close to her will get you
g6 beat for now
Well, yes, it’s probably important not to yawn, as it were
king at 67 would be a mistake photo thanks
but if you don’t yawn queens shinji 7 then
most likely it shouldn't be a big problem
while getting along 2 in order to have the same 7
wanted to keep two and down i can protect
a pawn by the way in this variation king h5
queens 6 king 6 she is true yes you can
I don't want to yes yes so like this
it makes sense to
well done again I don’t know c5 or again too
you have to choose between these two
there probably isn't much difference
but still goes for some option
the king looks like yes apparently maxim at all
not a ruble that 4 rows of maxims are not at all
believes that whites can look like this
position so let's listen went
behind the wheel h4 still really
there is some attempt to play even 5
let's say on the capture play the same 60 then
c2 play king same 5 i.e. this
pretty long clothes two kings 6
some kind of shadow having some kind of
demonstrating an attempt to pass to
no doubt
yes thoughtful
people hitting the camera all the time
and we don't even know who
blame it don't show the weight of the other
cameras to know yes I even had
Flag Though Desperately Thought To Role In 6
here to play but of course to lose
but in a position that you will spill now 7
step does not want no here before agneta position
who is now on the board is to lose
it's me again, the villains walked everyone
had a hard time and moreover we will continue
insist the same 6 to wonder that is
Maxim found an opportunity to give camp
do not give, let's say, a sketchy draw
gotta show it off
demonstrate some kind of counting will go
probably 5 again is not very clear
what else can be done instead
or by the way, and considering that youth
the pool could be a black boat again
wished maybe he forced one
against five will beat now in order to
get well 3 start with king as much as 50 like
it looks extremely unnatural
anyway, let's try to find a forced
draw here here 10 moves not really up to
22 business on signals wait a second I have
there is something flashing in my head
just cant highway up shah knows for
what will we finish playing even the 8th dorado
nakamura night yes don't shiver here is the king
h7 just well yes it's instructed again ta
the same himself, most likely the same 8 horse
should be a draw same 88 pies 65
rejoiced resolutely in culture to
lick more fields most likely by
feeling with such yes with such to some
borders when they must have time to reach
pawns a3 although also even here it is still
not quite not quite obvious too
will do it don't know anything yet
the king attacked the horse and everyone will have to
I'm going to go to the wand
and sold hold five I absolutely have
this is the next one by the way
not 7 and don't know how much we won't be yet
get involved in analyzing this position with
horse on live seeds frankly not
forced nakamura in this variant
you where we spent the unfortunate beat
natsu 2 is pathological to the woman
quite an idea to check the score after after
kolev shamil behind the wheel before the king again
the same kohl and just the same 7th move is wrong exactly
so the king is 5, well, you need to find
a clean draw in this position will calm down
most likely it is related to the creation
some kind of checkpoint on the upper flank i
can't see how without the queenside here
done immediately and draw b5 fl right up
before going to 75 now before
the problem is to live
still a pawn on 3 let's say in some
alia g7 positions will win your king 6
say king to 5 water beta 7
when we go from 5 to four white
internally, they also adjusted even 3 to
otherwise it’s completely natural if white
you had to beat a pcb king
drool will never have time to return and
to contend with in this respect can be
after all, it's raining as it was with us so far
this is worth a finger on the board come on
let's try as accurately as possible or fast
once again 5 same sem yes women 5 same md5 same
7 now we were giving check to king balls yea yea
here yes me some point already
I wanted to offer to play again, but there
getting along 6 upsets me the king and everyone
all of a sudden it happens
shah shah and chica roles in 6 well went there in
legs
let me lose the correspondence, that is, to me
would like to run the king gave taxiing
five let's go away to us in no but on
it is more profitable to have pawns a5 and d5 and c5 b5
because it won't be possible
as he is their relative 1 in the line of the king
threw the king far away and again in
this after we can not clean like
for youth 6 times a man needs to draw
arrows to put the rook in place and
just the same goes for the whole possession
the passage passes yes, yes, it didn’t suck
passes queen becomes write
agreed, well, that is, as it were, experience
suggests that dogs should be
probably a draw but offhand not
turns out to do him nothing so he's in 2
move without turning on the head will have a little
think of course hikaro and what is it and
can't eat the third one
yes, that's the pace because the pawn is the same
passes the check already by everyone on the next
go so yes not having time autocad
only if you give a couple of checks and therefore
then this one is natural to drive
king's knives to everyone and not even in hellas but
Well, of course, it is in this camp p713
yes, yes, and further in men completely
calmly give a rook for a pawn, yes
understands 85 before and that's it in a minute yet
While we
we can’t check, why am I already here
even here, well, actually cling to the same
7 we go own you check we eat more
just in case it's not bad
for example, you still need to assemble this boat
launch in such an arrangement on a boat
I'm taking away well, yes, well, as if why did I humiliate
4 there with a huge margin to give on
the output of black does not risk anything at all
yes, it is very competent to drive it
king forward and glands and
and just mechanically take away a pawn from and
so you don't have to think about anything
I really like this approach
I think that in the end on something
I'm becoming such a hikaru
and that all parties will end in a draw 20
20 20 20 of course but we are coastal yes
we take along to match them just the world
fabiano caruana vs undo game
but although on the other hand now in
london passes to the first set 1
100 Great Britain were there for sure
supporters of the party sci-fi archive it
still a little more like they hid
loose field even at the semi-final stage
no diluted composition therefore it is us
let's not count yes, well, not much
looks like he's holding two so that's enough
comfortable
it’s not very clear where the whites and turn
can but nowhere well how shah shah not
go shorter 7 sorry yes not go shorter
everyone can’t, well, you can’t in this position
beat on the pool go there not immediately
korolev 8 was already sitting here and now I
Black can change his mind there later
miracle make dates
insist that the king owns it
up to 5 queens 8
well true win we by 5 black no well
I'm so gone again that is not
dabbled
especially in general, you can play up to
if you leave two connected
actually yes you can yes and vanessa what
whites don't pretend to give the king knives
You can also play 8-bit
didn't seem reasonable at all
Yes, she would definitely pick everyone up
will be forced and then the canyon well this is us
Discussed there the pace of sensations still on
west pace 3 in those positions at least 7
here is this 9 queens about sympathy what
win the blackness police never
win but they also lose it too
never lose that is once again here
we came the year that the toughest t-55 and
on the same 7 I think that he is being kept does
nothing but why put it in the bowels of this
cars are much more technical when it looks like
not one there senior citizens can or
offer a draw immediately
fed 8 or spend some
quite a hefty amount of time
this is not the debit position we sow go we
let's go in response to this while we still have to
54 yes, well, in general, there is nothing special about
talk big big stock teach it
obviously simple
mixed yelling fun no funny
the hub is in that position so it's there
rechecked checks one by one
circle because all all the complex decided
not even before the 40th move already no no very much and
even 39 but bangur time then but here
Dana once again need to go back for a second and
praise hikaru because it's obvious that
he is all this milan you my before instead of
that we scolded him, yes, and I started everything
comments are a rookery but since I
with horror I imagine how much nonsense
we don't talk for the next two hours my
expectations in general not but in them were
deceived by reality but it is obvious that
this whole plan was conceived when he
walked get along water h8 yes indeed
a show for such and more arises
the question was whether it was more accurate to start an ambulance
for 20
we may not need us only 2 m
in order to prevent here channel 18 and let's go
king 3 let's try for sure
do not give the same
but maybe we're doing something else
in this way and of course in principle
the idea to raise a pawn went down even 5
as fast as possible, she is very, very
naturally must keep your game check
on the same 2 yes yes and it is quite possible that something
what the fics demonstrated again
we could not align saw that
we didn’t consider it an equation in any way
otherwise it did not work, that is, on occasion
this one follow kaladesh 8 moves
king and 86 this could be one of
few good ways to draw
here so you once again we
we observe that
as if the same draw smersh ahmad
and is explained by the increased
not only and maybe not even so much
like an arms race in the debut
and also the fact that people stopped
lose dangerous positions in which
have good social security before respectively
just take and defend
once again we see how
a man was caught in the debut forced
defend really pretty vile
very dangerous glasses he is with this yes he is what
fell asleep for a moment
surrounded for himself as if to decide what
strives for what does not strive gave
quite a lot of material along the way with it
to activate the figures and judging by
everything is quite comfortable to do here
nothing will hold two kings 6 on the board and
pita with data games here we maximize in
Basically, if he doesn't want to
all this how to say profanity can
go king same 5n i don't think u
speed up speed up the process gifts are not ours
profanity a little of course exaggerating
some profanity did not fit in this
look like this if you
engage on king g7 looks like that
pawn attack is strictly unity
occasional severe nissan honda
but again it's hard to imagine
why else would black drive the king to
the clearing wants to go on this think that I
introduced strongly no doubt that
it's the deadlight that we don't have, so what
another interesting idea
I will finally demonstrate against the option
sage 5 and now again at least
least summit second time her
probably won't be able to apply
black jada
blacks are all investigating there he's pretty
standard situation still to Speransky
the spire in particular was introduced so to
suits him he goes to the most
center lines and every time
shows some new idea one
he scared the game of magnus carlsen
well I remember in stavanger
sixteenth year or something
Magnus was also forced to sleep there
somewhere on the seventeenth try
painful to remember what is in it files
it is written, that is, such an approach
so you know what's most likely
against the optimal defense of the party you are not
succeed but nevertheless so one question
asked and remember this question specifically
the question is asked serious and ranji 7
get along water and managed a little
rehabilitate to find at least one
sane options yes we lied a lot
today in the process of broadcast 5 between scary
first of all, it seems to me, but in some places
doesn't look like a seaside venom needed satomi
after all, we guess something 12 well, so
try now it is not clear yes we sow
especially especially here there is no such thing
attempts, I think that some kind of option
of those that he showed and will
Demonstrated in waning sitting
Basin 7 Black will start on the c-pawn
white or give up exactly a rook for a pawn
c and take the rook for a pawn here or there
horse king and 8 king and 8 repetitions
it might turn out
well, yes, from queens 8 to in a good way
don't even need anything about all these moves
to speak because we all voiced it
Well, then what is some general well, yes and no
the current of the classical part and even then three
parts but one more thing a little probably
about today's match and you can say
came such
from violently funny news from next door
studios
borrowed from Fabian and such a funny one too
Indra Since Fabian Interview
obviously took it on the spot
alejandro miras who worked with him
second at the world championship match
they also have such a generally close relationship
and alejandro well, the question is general lies
on the surface asked Fabian how are you
Do you think they will target you
stroked her bugs in the table to hydrogen and
and Fabian in response to this said no, I do not
I think that's just what's happening
they have nothing there for the Russian party and
and Alikhan did not strongly insist, but
here are our neighbors in the English-speaking studio
even they considering it must be said that in
principle in St. Louis here, as it were
Fabian's standards caravans raised
extremely high we go to work by
its like cardboard to the shore then and
it's clear that its very supported here
he is very supportive and very much loved and
he's actually in charge here
chess hero even here are our neighbors
boot studio got a little divorced
hands and and were forced to look for what
How could he say that right?
when asked in an interview
perfectly understandable cooking
beat it fast it's quite the same
it is obvious that this is what
going on here's a kinda thing of course
such dynamics when 4 ultra strong
chess players and at the same time the whole field counts
what exactly would 40 of them need
one of them must be taken warm, but
here you know what moment yes probably
considers himself the favorite of the fast ones, but apart from
that's why yes that is maybe
not be as big as it looks
so I don't want to put
to bet on the classic park in
so to speak, anything can happen
whatever it is very expensive yes yes yes
it is not clear what, as it were, in a situation where
so different weights for classics and everything
the rest is accepted something like this
Roughly speaking, the mathematical solution of
that
it doesn't make sense these are some big
risks, but again, if conditionally speaking
them and
and fikar u or out today would have come out
because even even in the Russian party and
there is one question we asked on
this question would get some answers
on this party ended up in nothing
there was no such topic for
conversation but both in fact
just decided it's not a party at all
play give case with lemon it's special
it's amazing that he already has d4c 4d
will be completely toothless and a bunch
ideas, it’s not like it’s not the fact that
the game ended in a draw, and the fact that
and hikaru or is he good today
just took off this party rock and ain't no
I don't want to even imitate some
activity
let's say there is taken to the pool blow is worth
worth the actual position that we
who look while married before 38 thinks
how exactly to go I think we went
c5 in this finger I see no reason for this
don't u go dressed mine let
diverting it 73 shah allowing the head to everyone yes
well, it will go contain 3 then 75
counted where everyone counted to the end no
wire would three patrick the herd will enter
too play the skill well drums on
the win is, as it were, also for yourself, but
no vladi skinny whites go he see
the answer to this is ours
8 so that he does not run at all and will go
again here and the question is who is the first rook
actually win I think that apparently in
this idea is
not stupid either, although to be honest I
I don't think there is anything wrong with
position 5 up doesn't look hard to imagine
imagine the water cession lives there no yeah
are you ready for some kind of undertaking
because but again fall down king
submenu is it really not enough for us
tempus but then he won
the maximum number of paces to run
say even 7 now we can't water and
you will be deceived by a miner and a miner 8
further, well, yes, he again donata
Shakhnova 8 and drove the king kept there like
expected back to be up to 60 songs as
it’s generally possible where it’s possible not here
to be in time, well, yes, that is, here, as it were, more
moreover pawn c which is there before c2
Enough to have to go to get married on the idea
again, it's just a matter of taste
draw in this position
doesn't make a move maybe don't make
nothing here queens 6x queens 6 so in
general to the role in six she don't do but don't
so simple though also not but he's not here
does demanded today first of all
time to drive the king in front of the pawn before
king is 7 before but here again I think
what is the difference between king up 6 king up
5 principled no but king up 60 up
canada take talkin about
it is not necessary to indicate before that nothing but
yes, so maxim something else is not easy
they now destroy 5 what's all that
stands on the board steering wheel h7 c 4 f.m.
no but if if quite like this in a straight line
try to take away the internal mechanism
which you need to know, although most likely on
this and time, then there is no some Chaldean
818 but here, as it were, in quality
this is never an additional problem.
does not advance a pawn with the queen without capturing
rooks always have the cat larry basi
this can be relatively important
mechanism to be mentioned but it
let's go back yes yes already he played everyone
they don't plan to hold anything
generally up to the nose 4 and again a pawn already
we are also enough for everyone eric is already 73 yes
well, in general, there’s not much to say here
what is important not to blunder a pawn price
since the king get well 7 has
opportunities to protect
will attack played think that 17 king to 43
awaits us, but just like that, yes, well, or
same 8 then I own them less often and hard
until the queen is not dragged by the rook
spend at least 80 Shah Hellas swimming pool
budget
but no, I'm still a queen, okay, yes
enough to exercise, ok
ends
somehow finished incredibly quickly
today yes we were given we were given such a floor
day off but tomorrow we will have
full time
full cycle up to 6 games will be played tomorrow
well, everyone draws in london completely
incredible event not imperfect
incredibly incredible how
dragged on this series and how
the rule is as the walking one shows
practice is always someone being talked to
for drawing a draw series, she is right there
interrupted but stupidly until this time no
uninterrupted caught feeling
ambiguity still remains
yes yes now will look in
calendar when the next tournament is in
london by class next big
classic tournament is Wijk aan Zee
in which nothing like this happens
will not be, I can release very calmly
since it has long been noted that exactly
tournaments held in a form like
like a Wijk aan Zee tournament where
let's say 14 private traders are invited
78 people from the first
tens there sometimes 6 sometimes 9
depending on who this year
who wants to go to the northern sea
wants and invites pretty big
the amount of such fresh young blood then
there will be playing there this year
Fedoseev tire client sees out
tournament b last year, that is, there will be
such a mix in every round will be yes it is
this is the very moment ska which its time
Garry Kimovich Kasparov scored positively
but harry brick to the right as golden
years gained plus 7 in general
tournaments in which there was no mix
so I would not write off for a moment
I go there really to the Wijk aan Zee tournament
they are highly efficient
and there is nothing like that to ask
maybe that is, let's cancer be different
picture and again how I would like to
say death is classic chess
still somewhat exaggerated but
it is clear that in world championship matches
between basket level chess players and
caravans or tournaments like these
how is it how we that from observed where
44 chess players play like which one is there
registered for decades in 1 in the first
ten and underscore again
nakamura is now 2746 but we will be
ignore because we know such
nakamura is that she had bad
six months
we are generally not cheating and higher than the data
here before in general in the classics it happens that
it's not easy to win a game
Well, you are definitely someone tomorrow
win parasite accident won't get along
tribute don't forget to turn on at 8 am on
our local time would be 5
evenings in Moscow will begin the last
the final day in which for sure
determine the winner of the entire series
june raw verge hour tour and proper
winner of the match for third place again
we are reminded of the format of the tournament yes here
we finally have the top
shot back and there will be two parties left
two sets of 25 plus delays of 10
seconds and
4 blitz with control 5 plus delay three
and if you draw two games in extremely fast
rapid 10 plus, in my opinion, 5 if these are
tied then armageddon so
that potentially tomorrow we have a very
a lot of chess at least 2 on 12 parties
guaranteed in a chess game and
Potentially to this still on top of the party in
party 2 3 so come tomorrow we
we promise you
mass of action demos up to 1
look for feodosia
[music]
but
is he